welcome to this video playing chromos
from from from from Norway right the two
nights variation with this somewhat
weird line but it's not not bad yeah
come on let's try to be be head on the
clock once once in my life being head on
the clock
the funny thing is that I probably fall
behind quickly even if i start to be a
quicker then i'll invest the time later
okay what is this next move I was
thinking I thought 94-year is this a
move it looks that looks completely
wacky but he cannot castle and
threatening night c2 and on bishop yeah
this is what he was thinking maybe he
needs to play this this strange reply
okay night f5 though now on I'd be 5 95
s is also strange but okay maybe this
one okay now Bishop Bishop takes [ __ ]
shouldn't be too bad
so it's a it's a healthy structure term
some play against against the pawn here
on 1c3 let's see how is going to play
that maybe Bishop g2 intending see form
yes but if I retreat should I retweet it
I can also go to be 6 may be here if you
go see for I take with the pawn I'm
intending maybe even look see fall and
then take a phone mm-hmm now maybe and
I'm still ahead on the clock
you really wants to trade you if i go up
c5 where are you going taking Bishop
takes cannot be great okay this means
you probably just just retreats no he
doesn't but Roxy for is not bad right I
wonder if I have night g3 I know again
what he moved in I g3 rookie one mighty
force could be could be an interesting
way to play what about 90 for him
come on I've ever creative many many
weird ideas in this game and I'm going
to play them if it takes it i take d2
and win the d4 pawn at the end I hope if
he takes a five Bishop takes its app in
here hmm Jeff maybe don't really see a
big downside yes this is possible i can
put yet another look here come on let's
let's do that yeah the thing is if i
move the night then this Bishop e2 they
probably need to retreat again damn i
don't i don't think i can sacrifice the
exchange on c3b it's very unlikely i can
go here maybe yeah maybe come on let's
let's try to play to stay quick here if
he goes Bishop e2 a plane 95 and give up
the exchange okay
I maybe I should have played d4 maybe I
should have played deform it smells
better probably ok it's not not decisive
I hope
no yeah i think i'm going to take this
now he was threatening c4 anyway night
queen here this Bishop d3 this my queen
trapped don't tell me my queen strapped
this would be again completely
completely weird okay
Queen a 5c formally this is this is
disappointing in white was really in bad
shape no no question and now it's even
playing for when I'm not sure based on
what but he's trying to do that where
the Queen came can try to try to argue
that the queen is Sir it's in a bad bad
shape IAM the shop you won or what maybe
I really cannot believe that white
should be better here with the Queen on
be to end and all that it's really
unlikely
and the time will decide this very
likely I came not sure that that's
really a threat
time warning no no mate on HH ha ha ha
ha ok black resigned ah yeah at least
very very very unnecessary of course
yeah i mean if you really should take
the draw i think here yeah okay yeah
well it's it doesn't help i mean you can
quote computer evertz all the time this
is completely winning for black pepper
it's it still needs to be played and i
didn't i didn't didn't prevent this
counter play really yeah minus three but
what what what good did it do me came
probably i just need to take with the f
porn I don't know I mean it's easier to
play for white it just needs to get
everything near the King I'd hope to win
also I was trying to defuse matters here
with this this capture but it's not it's
not really working this was a nice reply
yeah yeah it's it just completely
completely lost ah yeah yeah maybe I
could have killed this off before around
here I cannot really believe this is
losing time and time and time no way
that this is ever going to be good for
right I can take a 4 here maybe I should
do that yeah it is it's just a messy
blitz tough man look at this I mean what
is of course not good but
at the end you need to be technically
alert which I wasn't okay thanks for
watching